Today is the photoshoot for my clothing line
Ghost and Stars.
Pretend we're taking a photo!
Starting my own clothing line is something that
I've wanted to do for a really long time.
And I wanted to have a bunch of my friends come out
and wear my apparal and get avant-garde
futuristic makeup.
The makeup and hair people are obviously amazing so
it was fun to just get to feel like another creature for the day.
And everyone has been such a good sport
and so talented and so beautiful!
Our photographer and me will just be like
screaming at people like: You're adorable!
You're beautiful!
I'm stoked to be surrounded by so many cool chicks.
Anna picked a lot of lovely women that are both like
awesome looking and just awesome to hang out with.
I love avant-garde makeup.
So when I started thinking about how I wanted
to present the clothes, I was like well
I mean, we can like do avant-garde
and like make everyone kind of look like aliens
or like they're from the future
like really high fashion
so that when you go the website it doesn't just look like
oh here's a bunch of like products you can buy
but it's just a lot of interesting images from a lot of
different, adorable friends of mine.
"Girl Fight" is what I'm wearing.
I think the shirt is about being strong, powerful.
My little sister is here, she was so excited
when I told her this was happening
because she looks up to Anna.
And she wants a shirt.
This is an amazing shirt, it has a
Catstronaut, I think you said?
It's a Cat Astronaut and it's basically my goal in life.
This is a first design that I wanted.
and it was actually done by my best friend
in North Carolina, Jessica Balacy.
I was like, I really want a cat shirt.
I have to have a cat shirt because
that's kind of why I wanted a clothing line--was
because I wanted shirts that I could wear all the time.
And so when I said
Hey can you make me like a cat in space or like a cat astronaut?
She sent me this and it has become my favorite design
because I have four cats and I love cats
and this one is an astronaut.
Oh, the shirt is sweet dude
I'm so stoked that I own this now.
Plus I love that it's Anna's face on my shirt.
There's like multiple components that are like, great.
It says "Oh My Stars" and the "A" is holding
all my stars.  Like balloons.
I like kind of busy clothes
so I can pair it with more busy stuff.
I don't know if you can tell from the pictures
but it's really soft.
I have the Hallucination shirt.
Uhm, it's just really cute with some little hearts
going on, so we just did a whole theme where I don't know
maybe you're hallucinating.  Crazy face.
It is math inspired because I don't think
any of this is real or correct.
Uhm, I like to call them Cat-culations.
Ah!
Ghost and Stars was something that I found in my diary
a long time ago.
I used to just like to write words or phrases
and so when I was thinking about what to call
the clothing line, I didn't want it to be "Anna Akana"
and I didn't want it to be my face
or like "Stay Awesome Gotham" or anything like that.
I was like no I want to make clothes that I would actually wear
in real life for any occasion.
I would wear this shirt probably
like out during the day but you could also like
tuck it in a pair of skanky hot pants
and like wear them with some tights and rock it at night.
What I know is that she started this from the ground up.
That she is doing this on her own.
She decided to make this company
and she's doing it.  It's out of her closet, it's out of her
house.  Which is insane.
Thank you so much to the crew, thank you so much to the models,
and thanks for making my dream come true.
And if you'd like a shirt you can get it at GhostandStars.com
Yay!  Stay Awesome Gotham.